« Environ 115 milligrammes d'oxycodone, ai-je répondu.
Peut-être plus. »
J'étais nonchalant, j'avais donné cette information à beaucoup de médecins,
de nombreuses fois auparavant,
mais là, c'était différent.
Mon médecin est devenu sérieux,
m'a regardé et a dit :
« Travis, cela fait beaucoup d'opiacés.
Vous devez songer à arrêter les médicaments. »
En deux mois,
c'était la première fois que quelqu'un se montrait inquiet.
C'était la première vraie conversation
au sujet de mon traitement aux opiacés.
On ne m'avait pas donné d'avertissement,
pas de conseils,
pas de stratégie...
Juste beaucoup d'ordonnances.
Ce qu'il s'est passé ensuite définit le vécu de mon traumatisme médical.
On m'a donné ce que, maintenant, je sais être une posologie trop dégressive
selon laquelle j'ai divisé mes médicaments en quatre doses,
diminuant d'une dose par semaine durant le mois.
Le résultat est que j'ai déclenché un syndrome de sevrage aigu des opiacés.
Autrement dit, le résultat
fut l'enfer.
Les premières phases du sevrage ressemblent à une mauvaise grippe.
J'étais nauséeux,
j'ai perdu mon appétit,
j'avais mal partout,
j'avais plus mal à mon pied mutilé ;
j'avais du mal à dormir du fait d'une sensation générale d'agitation.
A l'époque,
je pensais que cela était épouvantable.
C'est parce que j'ignorais ce qui allait suivre.
Au début de la deuxième semaine,
ma vie s'est détériorée.
Alors que l'intensité des symptômes augmentait,
mon thermostat interne a semblé se détraquer.
Je suais abondamment presque constamment
et pourtant si j'arrivais à sortir sous le chaud soleil d'août,
je pouvais me retrouver avec la chair de poule.
L'agitation qu'il rendait mon sommeil difficile la première semaine
s'était transformée en ce que je croyais être une sensation de sevrage.
J'avais des sueurs froides qui me faisaient tressaillir.
Il m'était presque impossible de dormir.
Mais le plus troublant, c'étaient les pleurs.
Je me retrouvais avec les larmes aux yeux
sans raison apparente
et sans aucun avertissement.
A l'époque, cela semblait être un raté neuronal
similaire à la chair de poule.
Sadiye a commencé à s'inquiéter et a appelé le médecin prescripteur
qui a serviablement conseillé beaucoup de fluides pour la nausée.
Quand elle a insisté et a dit : « Il n'est vraiment pas bien »,
le médecin a répondu : « S'il est si mal,
il peut revenir à la dose précédente pendant quelque temps.
- Et après ?
- Réessayez plus tard. ».
Je n'allais pas en revenir à la dose précédente
à moins d'avoir une meilleure stratégie pour le sevrage la fois d'après.
Nous avons poursuivi et diminué d'une autre dose.
Au début de la troisième semaine,
mon monde est devenu très sombre.
J'ai arrêté de manger
et je dormais à peine
à cause des sueurs froides qui me faisaient frémir toute la nuit.
Mais le pire,
le pire fut la dépression.
Les larmes qui semblaient être un raté auparavant
semblaient véritables.
Plusieurs fois par jour, l'émotion me prenait à la poitrine,
comme quand les larmes montent,
mais je ne pouvais pas les arrêter
et avec elles sont venues le désespoir et la détresse.
J'ai commencé à croire que je ne me remettrais jamais
de l'accident ou du sevrage.
Sadiye a rappelé le médecin prescripteur
et il a recommandé de contacter l'équipe de gestion de la douleur
de la dernière hospitalisation.
Cela semblait être une super idée,
ce fut fait immédiatement
et nous avons été choqués que personne ne veuille nous parler.
Le réceptionniste qui a répondu au téléphone nous a informés
que l'équipe de gestion de la douleur ne s'occupait que des patients hospitalisés.
S'ils prescrivent des opiacés pour contrôler la douleur,
ils ne supervisent pas la diminution ou le sevrage des médicaments.
Furieux, nous avons rappelé le médecin et avons imploré quelque chose --
quoi que ce soit qui puisse m'aider --
mais il s'est excusé,
se disant dépassé.
« Écoutez, nous a-t-il dit,
mon conseil initial était clairement mauvais.
Ma recommandation officielle est que Travis reprenne ses médicaments
jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve quelqu'un de plus compétent pour le sevrer. »
Bien sûr que je voulais reprendre mes médicaments.
C'était une agonie.
Mais je croyais que si je m'épargnais le sevrage des médicaments,
je ne serais jamais libre,
alors nous nous sommes accrochés
et j'ai arrêté la dernière dose.
Alors que mon cerveau vivait sans ordonnance d'opiacés
pour la première fois depuis des mois,
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir.
J'ai supposé que j'allais mourir --
(Pleurs)
Désolé.
Car si les symptômes ne me tuaient pas,
je me suiciderais.
Je sais que cela semble dramatique
car, à mes yeux, en me tenant là des années plus tard,
en bonne santé --
pour moi, cela semble dramatique.
Mais je le croyais vraiment
car je n'avais plus aucun espoir
d'être à nouveau normal.
L'insomnie est devenue insupportable
et, après deux jours sans sommeil,
j'ai passé une nuit entière sur le sol de notre salle de bains.
J'ai alterné entre refroidir ma tête enfiévrée
contre le carrelage en céramique
et essayer de vomir violemment en n'ayant pas mangé depuis des jours.
Quand Sadiye m'a trouvé à la fin de la nuit,
elle a été horrifiée
et nous avons décroché le téléphone.
Nous avons appelé tout le monde :
les chirurgiens, les médecins gérant la douleur, les généralistes --
tous ceux que nous trouvions sur internet
et pas un seul d'entre eux ne m'a aidé.
Les rares auxquels nous avons parlé au téléphone
nous ont conseillé de reprendre les médicaments.
Une clinique indépendante de gestion de la douleur a dit prescrire des opiacés
mais ne pas superviser la diminution ou le sevrage des médicaments.
Quand mon désespoir s'est clairement entendu dans ma voix,
comme maintenant,
la réceptionniste a inspiré profondément et dit :
« M. Rieder, il semble qu'il vous faille un centre de désintoxication
ou une clinique de méthadone. »
Ne sachant pas quoi faire, j'ai suivi son conseil.
J'ai raccroché et j'ai appelé ces endroits-là,
mais il ne m'a pas fallu longtemps
pour découvrir que nombre de ces établissements
s'adressent à ceux luttant contre l'abus de drogues à long terme.
Dans le cas des opiacés,
cela implique souvent de ne pas sevrer le patient
mais de passer aux opiacés plus sûrs, à action prolongée :
la méthadone ou la buprénorphine pour un traitement de maintien.
En outre, tous les endroits que j'appelais avaient une longue liste d'attente.
Je n'étais pas le genre de patient pour lequel ils étaient prévus.
Après été refusé dans un centre de désintoxication,
j'ai fini par admettre ma défaite.
J'étais mal en point, vaincu
et je n'en pouvais plus.
J'ai dit à Sadiye que j'allais reprendre des médicaments.
Je prendrais la dose la plus faible possible
et je prendrais ce qui était absolument nécessaire
pour échapper aux effets les plus dévastateurs du sevrage.
Cette nuit-là, elle m'a aidé à monter
pour aller au lit, la première fois depuis des semaines.
J'ai pris le flacon orange de médicaments,
je l'ai posé sur ma table de nuit...
et je n'y ai pas touché.
Je me suis endormi,
j'ai dormi toute la nuit
et à mon réveil,
les symptômes les plus sévères s'étaient considérablement estompés.
Je m'en étais sorti.
(Applaudissements)
Merci, cela a aussi été ma réaction.
(Rires)
Alors --
désolé, j'ai besoin d'un instant.
Je pense que cette histoire est importante.
Non pas que je me crois spécial.
Cette histoire est importante précisément car je ne suis pas spécial,
rien de ce qui m'est arrivé n'était exceptionnel.
Ma dépendance aux opiacés était entièrement prévisible
étant données la quantité prescrite
et la durée de la prescription.
La dépendance est la réponse naturelle du cerveau
à un environnement riche en opiacés
et donc, dès le début, tout poussait à penser
que j'aurais besoin d'une stratégie de sevrage supervisé,
mais notre système de santé n'a pas l'air d'avoir décidé
qui est responsable des patients comme moi.
Les prescripteurs me voyaient comme un patient complexe
ayant besoin de soins spécialisés,
d'analgésiques.
Les médecins de gestion de la douleur considéraient devoir la contrôler
et quand je n'ai pas pu arrêter les médicaments,
pour eux, cela relevait de la toxicomanie.
Le traitement de la toxicomanie est surchargé
et se concentre sur ceux souffrant de toxicomanie à long terme.
En bref, on m'a prescrit un médicament nécessitant une gestion à long terme
et je n'ai pas eu cette gestion
et il n'était même pas clair de qui relevait cette gestion.
C'est la recette d'un désastre
et il est intéressant et cela mérite de parler de ce désastre --
cela mérite une intervention TED --
mais l'échec du sevrage des opiacés est une inquiétude particulière
en ce moment en Amérique
car nous sommes au beau milieu d'une épidémie
durant laquelle 33 000 personnes sont mortes d'overdose en 2015.
La moitié de ces morts impliquait la prescription d'opiacés.
La communauté médicale a commencé à réagir à la crise
mais leur réponse a surtout été de prescrire moins de cachets --
absolument, c'est important.
Par exemple, nous avons des preuves
que les médecins américains prescrivent souvent des médicaments
même quand ce n'est pas nécessaire
dans le cas des opiacés.
Et quand des opiacés sont nécessaires,
ils prescrivent souvent bien plus que nécessaire.
Ce genre de considérations aident à expliquer pourquoi les États-Unis,
s'ils ne représentent que 5% de la population mondiale,
consomment près de 70% de la production mondiale d'opiacés.
Mais se concentrer uniquement sur le taux de prescription
risque de négliger deux points cruciaux.
Le premier est que les opiacés sont
et continueront d'être d'importants traitements contre la douleur.
Ayant souffert d'une douleur sévère, réelle et durable,
je peux vous assurer que ces médicaments peuvent rendre la vie soutenable.
Deuxièmement :
nous pouvons lutter contre l'épidémie en prescrivant des opiacés judicieusement
aux gens qui en ont vraiment besoin,
en exigeant que les médecins gèrent correctement
les cachets qu'ils prescrivent.
Par exemple,
revenons-en à la posologie dégressive que l'on m'a donnée.
Est-il raisonnable de s'attendre
à ce que tout médecin prescrivant des opiacés
sache que c'est trop agressif ?
Après avoir publié mon histoire dans un journal académique,
quelqu'un du centre pour le contrôle des maladies
m'a envoyé leur guide sur le sevrage des opiacés.
C'est un document de quatre pages,
majoritairement des images.
Dedans, ils apprennent aux médecins les cas simples de sevrage des opiacés
et l'une de leurs recommandations
est de ne jamais commencer
par une diminution de plus de 10% par semaine.
Si mon médecin avait eu ce guide,
mon sevrage aurait duré quelques mois plutôt que quelques semaines.
Je suis sûr que cela n'aurait pas été facile.
Cela aurait probablement été désagréable,
mais cela n'aurait peut-être pas été l'enfer.
Cela semble être le genre d'informations
que quelqu'un prescrivant ces médicaments doit avoir.
Pour finir,
je dois dire que gérer correctement les opiacés prescrits
ne résoudra pas la crise en soi.
L'épidémie américaine est bien plus vaste que cela,
mais quand un médicament est responsable de dizaines de milliers de morts par an,
une gestion désinvolte de ce médicament n'est pas défendable.
Aider les patients traités aux opiacés à arrêter les médicaments
qu'on leur a prescrits
n'est peut-être pas une solution intégrale à notre épidémie,
mais cela serait un progrès.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)